money
come to me own three different jets in
my life and I and use them and just
burning them up for the Lord Jesus right
now someone is about to send you that
million dollar check in the name of
Jesus you just seemly need to be
obedient whether it's $100,000 whether
it's $10,000 so do you make any
apologies for your grand piano I really
don't opra we just feel like this is
God's blessings do you ever watch Tyler
Olivivera on YouTube. I've seen some
videos of him. Yeah. Yeah. Same. Same.
So, he's got he he really blew up. He's
got like 7 million subscribers right
now. Pretty big YouTuber in the field of
like I guess like you know the the the
titles that say I investigated such and
such. Um yeah. So, he made a video
recently that got like 4 million views
in I don't know just a couple days where
he basically goes around to these mega
churches where the prosperity gospel is
preached and Yeah. where they, you know,
obviously collect a lot of money and the
pastors are usually very rich. Uh he's
got Kenneth Copeland on the thumbnail
here. Yeah. Um it's pretty cool
thumbnail. Yeah. Yeah. So anyway, so
that's what he did and he exposed a lot
of these these prosperity gospel
megaurches and you know, I kind of want
to talk about that because I feel like a
lot of people will see this kind of
gospel and think that's what
Christianity really is. And we'll see a
couple comments at the end of this video
where Yeah. like Christianity is looked
upon as a big joke, right? And it's
looked upon as as as deceptive. And I
get why. Yeah. It's it's it it's hard
when you're trying to witness as a
Christian and people have a different
perspective of of Christianity because
of, you know, certain types of
Christians that preach different
versions of the gospel, right, that
don't really align with the gospel, with
the actual gospel. Yep. So, let's let's
dive in. Uh Tyler had this intro to his
uh almost hour-long video and so this
kind of summarizes what we're going to
talk about. So let's let's dive in.
That's me confronting the $60 million
televangelist Benny Hinn. Benny Hinn is
a false prophet, fake healer, and state
oil salesman.
We're going to get into the scriptures.
Can we do that now? He lives in a $10
million mansion. bought a private jet
with donations from the churchgoers and
has made his riches by claiming to
perform miracles, mercy, and grace.
[Music]
Is healing divine and by preaching the
prosperity gospel? Basically, the idea
that the more money you give to God, the
more money God gives to you. Are you
facing a financial difficulty right now?
There's only one way out of it. Give to
the Lord. Even that little you have
left, give it to God. The only problem
is your money goes straight to Benny's
bank account while your wallet gets a
prayer. He told me that my vision would
be 2020, if not better. Couple hours
later, it was just like now I can't see
the TV. And Benny's not the only one
who's made millions preaching the
prosperity gospel to desperate people in
need of a miracle. Joel, I have a
question for you. Do you think you've
used the Lord's word to profit?
Let's begin our investigation into the
world of false prophets at Kenneth
Copelan's church. He made that airplane
so cheap for me, I couldn't help but buy
it. Perhaps the scariest and richest
pastor in the world. I am a rich Jew
backed by a richer Jew. Oh, wow. I'm
totally invested. Yeah. So, this is the
prosperity gospel. Have you heard of it?
Oh, I Yeah, I've I've heard of it. I've
never um been to a church or heard a
sermon from you know people who preach
the prosperity gospel. Right. But I've
I've heard of that they are out there.
Right. Right. I mean we all know of
Kenneth Copeland, Joel Olstein. Um I
mean even Benny Hinn, Paula White.
Interesting side note here. Um, there is
photo footage of uh uh Paula White and
Benny Hinn supposedly having an affair
on their own spouses. It was like a
couple years ago. So, wow. Interesting.
But anyway, so yeah, you know, it makes
me really sad that this is out there
because
I don't we'll look at a couple verses in
just a second, but I don't I don't think
that this is how God is is is portrayed
in the Bible. Mhm. You know, when you
think of Jesus riding a lowly mule,
right? Like he wasn't driving a Tesla.
And and here here's the other thing is
that I I don't believe that
having wealth
is wrong or unbiblical. Solomon was the
richest man in the world. I think you
said or maybe it was somebody else in
the office who said that if you
calculate Solomon's wealth to today,
he'd still be the richest man today by
far. likes, right? Like trillions of
dollars and that was God blessing them,
right? Um same with Abraham was wealthy,
you know, David was wealthy. Yeah. But
it just depends on what you do with that
wealth. There was like a question that
was was raised here that I think it's
very valid. That is are you using the
are you using the the the Lord's name
for prophet? M what's a another way of
of um
wording it that wording this question?
Are you using the the Lord's name in
vain? M yeah good point because like
like you said it's good that we put it
on the table. It's not wrong. It's not
sinful to be wealthy.
But God does not promise wealth. I'm
sorry. Abraham was wealthy. Job was
wealthy. Uh Solomon, like you said, he
would still be the richest um man on
earth, but none of these were like using
God's name for prophet. Jesus, like you
said, also rode on a on a donkey. Mhm.
And he did not ride on a big healthy
horse called Ferrari
to walking to Jerusalem. Mhm. Or
anything like that. So yeah, there is
there's a line to be drawn here. We're
not saying that being rich is it's not a
sin. It's not a sin. No. And we're not
saying that if you work in ministry and
you have some amount of wealth is wrong
either. We do believe that God blesses.
Mhm. Right. But they there are ways and
I think we're going to explore here um
how they are doing it. Yeah. Right.
Because there it's it's misguiding
uh people on what Christianity is. Well,
I wanted to respond to what you said
about um that there's peop you can be a
ministry and be wealthy. Um years ago,
we interviewed these this couple from
Indonesia that they were really rich.
Like she came from a rich family and he
worked his way into wealth and they
basically became reconverted, came back
to the faith and then started a a TV
ministry. No clue if they're still rich
today or not. It's not up to my
business. But the fact is that at the
time when we know that they were rich,
they decided to use it for God's work,
right? To invest that money in God's
work. And I think this is how God wants
us to use money when we have it. Whether
we have little, whether we have much, if
you have little, maybe you can bake a
loaf of bread for your neighbor and
befriend them and then that's a way to
tell them about Jesus and Jesus' love
for you. Or maybe your you have nothing.
Your other neighbor over there, they
have a broken down car. you know how to
fix cars, you have nothing, but you
have, you know, a gift to give that way.
I think that's the principle of whatever
you're given, use it to God's glory.
Yeah. Wealth is not only calculating the
amount of money you have. Yes. The
skills and gifts that God gives you.
Mhm. It's it also counts. Yep. Right.
Yeah. So, Tyler, he goes to Kenneth
Copeland's church. Like he said, he's
probably the one of the most well-known
pastors of the whole world. And uh yeah,
he has an interesting experience there.
I was actually quite surprised to see
what he discovered there. Obviously, he
went undercover with like a hidden
camera and stuff or like a they're
filming with the phone, I think. So, I
headed inside to see what the fuss was
all about. Could this somehow be a
misunderstood church with a lead pastor
that happens to be worth hundreds of
millions of dollars? As I entered the
church doors, the first thing I noticed
was Kenneth Copelan's store selling
everything you could think of and the
Bible somewhere. That is fire. That's a
God approved hat. After purchasing a $38
Copeland hat, it was time to go to
church and listen to what they had to
say. And we don't have to do a whole lot
of deep dive into scripture to just find
that from the Bible, from the word of
God, his will for you is that you
prosper. About Abraham in Genesis 12 and
starting Genesis 12 and on, the very
first thing that God did to ratify the
blessing on Abraham's life was he
brought him out and he made him rich.
And church, I'm here to announce to you
today, he's still bringing us out and
he's still making us rich. He's still
bringing us out and he's still making us
rich. He will deliver you. He will set
you on high because you've known his
name. When you call upon him, he will
answer you. He will be with you in
trouble. And he always intends to bring
you out because he's trying to get
something from you, but because he's
trying to get something to you. He says,
"Be a giver." Why? because I'm a giver.
So, I want you to be a giver. Therefore,
you step into the covenant. So, this
morning, you get an opportunity to
exercise on Mother's Day what your
mother would say. Do what you've been
told. God wants to bless you. So, step
into the blessing. Amen. So, if you're
giving this morning, you can make your
checks payable to EMIC for cash, credit,
or debit giving. There's an envelope on
the seat back in front of you which will
populate there. Or you can text to give.
This is one of our most popular ways.
text 36609.
Happy Mother's Day and ushers. When the
people are ready, you can wait on the
people. Praise God. As the ushers
collected donations, I was happy to
learn they also accepted credit card,
but was surprised they didn't take
crypto. But as the sermon began, I
learned that a lot of this church's
message was to basically claim blessings
from God. And if you had enough faith,
your life would be blessed. And if you
didn't receive a blessing, it was
because you didn't have enough faith.
You know, Sister Gloria really has
taught us so much about what it means to
apply the principles of prosperity uh
that we find in the word of God. And the
words prosperity and faith were
repeatedly emphasized throughout the
sermon. Sort of like we were casting a
spell upon ourselves. Brother Copelan
has taught this statement and that is
this. Faith begins where the will of God
is known. And there may be those of you
who have never heard this before. God's
will is for you to walk in prosperity.
Uh 3R John 1:2 says, "Beloved, I pray
that you may prosper in every way." Say,
"Every way."
So prosperity is God's will for you. The
issue is is sometimes when we hear
prosperity, we think money. But that is
a limited view of what prosperity is. It
includes your money. That's right. But
it also includes your marriage. Amen. It
includes your family, God. It includes
our finances. Amen. My interpretation of
this sermon is that God is like a
miracle machine where I can will
miracles into my life. And if I give him
my faith and money, he will give me
whatever I desire. Ultimately, God is
there to make my life amazing. And after
a sprinkle of sermon, this church began
plugging harder than most YouTubers. And
in addition, for the people in the room
at the Word Works bookstore, we have a
Mother's Day sale going on. special
items you see up there. Special items
are up to 50% off and everything is up
to 20% off so you can celebrate the
mothers in your life with a special gift
today. So again, thank you so much,
moms. We honor you and we are so
grateful for you. As this old man began
preaching, it was clear that Kenneth was
nowhere to be found and was probably
taking a nap in his mansion on the
property right next to his private jet.
Okay, thoughts. I've only heard I only
heard one Bible verse mentioned in the
whole thing. Well, he he mentioned one
John uh sorry 3 John 1 vers 2 and three
says, "Beloved, I pray that you may
prosper in all things and be in health
just as your soul prospers." But he also
talks about Abram I guess like when God
pulled him out of right you know if you
think about the first and the third John
the author wasn't even rich himself so
that that in itself already tells you
that we're talking about different kind
of prosperity. Yeah because Jesus says
whoever collects riches on earth you
know you're not really collecting
anything up there because here you know
uh the riches they they rust. Mhm. You
got thieves that steal and all that
stuff, but collect riches in heaven.
That's literally what Jesus is saying
the entire time. Yeah. And another quote
verse they didn't say was a verse that
they mentioned was like, "I will deliver
you and I will take care of you and all
that stuff, but it it it's not saying
about um riches or anything like that,
right?" It's probably from like a Psalms
when David was going through trouble.
Mhm. Or just came back from war. Mhm.
But it's like just because God says he
will pro take care of you or that he
will protect you or that I will guide
you, that does not necessarily mean, you
know, Yeah. I I I I feel like and and to
to respond to what you said about Stuart
Richardson, heaven on earth, I think
that also has to do with the perspective
of if you have wealth, spend it on God's
things, you know, like spend it wisely.
um like and that's because then you
store up your riches in heaven so to
speak. But um you know I feel like the
way the prosperity gospel comes across
to me and I mean this very respectfully
to people who believe in this to me it
feels like a gumball machine kind of
process where it's like I want this and
so I'm going to claim it and I'm going
to believe in it and they say if it
doesn't come you just don't have enough
faith. Yeah. So it's very much to me it
feels very selfish and self-centered
and you know to think about that there's
lots of Christians even today who are
being persecuted who um let's say
communist China for example maybe in
Russia maybe in even in places like
Africa um back in the day in Europe in
the dark ages where millions of people
like I think the estimate is like 50
million people laid down their life for
the sake of the gospel. Do all these
people not have enough faith because
they were poor and they were killed for
their faith? I think they have more
faith than us me today, you know. So I I
think that concept of faith is kind of
misported here 100%. You know, yeah,
because faith is not about receiving
right something, right? Faith is is
believing that God will be with you no
matter what. You know, whether you're
rich, whether you're poor, whether
you're free or in prison, you know, you
believe God is there and he will do it.
Because Jesus said like if you have if
you have faith the size of a seed of a
mustard. He doesn't say then you have
all the riches of the world, you'll be
king or anything like that. No, you say
to this mountain, move from here to
there or cast yourself in the sea. Mhm.
He doesn't ever mention anything like
that. And the thing you said about like,
yeah, if if you don't receive, it means
you don't have enough faith. I keep uh
thinking about the story of the widow
that gave two coins. Mhm. And Jesus said
she gave more than all the other people
that pour all their buckets full of
coins in there. Because it was never
about how much you give, right? It's
about the intention of your heart. Yeah.
And she gave everything she had, not not
everything that was left.
Knowing that she was not going to
receive anything in return. That's
right. That's right. And that's
something that I think as well cuz
that's something that Benny Hinn said in
the intro clip. He said, "Well, if you
need something, do you need more? Like,
are you in need of wealth? Give and the
Lord will give back to you." Financially
speaking, but she gave not expecting
anything in return. You know, she just
gave because she loved God and she
wanted to further God's work. Yeah. And
I'm not saying that everybody should be
poor. I'm not saying like you should,
you know, go give everything away and
live on the streets. I think it's how
what is God's will for your life? What
is God's will for you to do? Right? If
it it's God's will for you to um you
know, sell everything and maybe you're
like maybe you are really rich and God's
calling you sew everything, give to the
church and then go live like this just
like he did basically with the rich
young ruler, right? The reason why that
was an issue with the rich young rulers
because his heart was selfish. He was
keeping all of the commandments toward
God and not commandments, the last six
commandments that were for man, like
loving man. The issue was never that he
was rich. No, it was that's not the
problem. Exactly. So really, it's like
what is God's will for your life and
what is God telling you to do? What is
he convicting you of through the
scriptures and through the Holy Spirit?
And it's never about well if I just
believe then God's gonna give me all
this wealth. And so 2 Corinthians 8:9
says for you know the grace of our Lord
Jesus Christ that though he was rich yet
for your sakes he became poor that you
through his poverty might become rich.
This is one of the verses that the
prosperity gospel people use. But let's
look at the Strongs accordance. I love
the Strongs concordance. I love using it
and like looking up the Hebrew and Greek
uh Aramaic definitions of of words in
the Bible. There's no better way to
understanding the Bible than to going
straight to the source. Right. Exactly.
So when you look at the last word rich
that says that you through his poverty
might become rich does it mean wealth
like like material wealth? Well, let's
take a look. So this is uh this is word
number G4145 in the strong concordance
and it says it could be meaning wealthy
abounding in material resources. Okay.
So there's there's that uh
metaphorically abounding abundantly
supplied or abounding rich in Christian
virtues and eternal possessions. So
there there comes in comes the concept
of store up your riches in heaven.
Right? like like when you out of genuine
faith in Jesus and love for Jesus and
fellow man do good for other people,
Jesus takes that and he sees it as like
a as like storing up your riches in
heaven. I don't think it means like, oh,
you're going to be like this millionaire
in heaven every time you do something
good for somebody else. It's it's it's a
reward. Whatever the reward may be, he
has a reward for us in heaven. Mhm. But
so now it has an option of meaning
material wealth or the other one
Christian abounding in in Christian
virtues and eternal possessions. So for
in order for us to understand which one
could be applied here you have to read e
the context of you know surrounding that
verse or just a context in the Bible in
general. What does the Bible say
elsewhere about wealth? That's how we
understand which one to apply here.
Well, Matthew 6:19-21 says,"Do not lay
up for yourselves treasures on earth,
where moth and rust destroy, where
thieves break in and steal, but lay up
for yourselves treasures in heaven,
where neither moth nor rust destroys,
and where thieves do not break in and
steal. For where your treasure is, there
your heart is also." Mhm. So, in other
words, maybe don't focus on material
things, but again, out of love for God
and other people, and your reward will
be waiting for you in heaven, but we
shouldn't do anything for the reward. We
should do it out of love for Jesus. And
like where your treasure is, there your
heart is also. That that verse right
there is key. That sums it up. Yeah.
Sums it up. So So what do what do you
understand that to mean when you read
that? Again, going back to the young
ruler, the problem was never that he was
rich, right? Because he never said that
to Job. Job was really rich, probably
one of the richest people uh on earth
when he was alive. Mhm. He never told
Abraham, "Move um out of earth and leave
your possessions behind." Yeah. Or he
never told Job, "Get out of there and
leave all your possessions behind." Or
any other, you know, uh rich person
character in the Bible. It was never
about that. Yep. He he understood what
was in their hearts. And even for
Abraham, the problem was not his riches.
He never gave a test regarding the
money. He gave the test regarding his
son. go and sacrifice your son. Not go
and sacrifice your money. Mhm. Right. So
when it says where your heart is, where
your treasure is, your heart will be
also. God is literally telling you like
do you love money more or me? That's
right. That's Jesus says you cannot
serve two masters. You cannot serve
money and God. Right. Because it shows
that you know the root of all evil can
really be one of them can be money.
Right. That's right.
It was funny that um well the the clip
it was showing that the entrance you go
right into the store and Tyler mentioned
it was like yeah you have everything
from books and and and and uh bags and
everything and I'm sure there's a Bible
somewhere you know it's like man what do
you mean it's the entrance of the church
first of all second of all they were
like selling stuff up front up front
everything 50% off 20% off Jesus flipped
the tables because they were doing that
right right in his sanctuary behind a
temple in and I I searched up um Kenneth
Copelan's net worth at some point it was
$750 million. That's insane. In 2024 it
was $300 million but 2021 was $750
million. Yeah. That he gets out of
Would it be too strong of a word to say
exploiting people's faith? No, I think
it's true because sadly it is something
that that he is doing using the Bible
forget. Yeah. Jesus Jesus said, "I will
not be with you always here on earth
physically, but the poor will always be
with you." Mhm. This is your chance to
go and help them. Use what you have to
help them. Yeah. Not use them to help
you. Right. You know, Yeah. Put it in
reverse. in and the the perfect the
perfect church when it began it was
everyone helping each other and nobody
told them to Peter didn't didn't tell
people hey start giving uh helping the
widows and giving your money to the poor
everything like that no everyone in
unison everyone had the same mind and
started helping each other that's what
Christianity was meant to be right I
mean the rich were donating their money
the poor whatever they had would
probably give their money as well and
they would basically just say Okay, how
can we divide this up to help all of all
of all of our people out? And and I'm
sure it even gave money to people who
weren't even believers yet. I'm sure of
that because that's the mindset. Yeah.
And at that time around that same period
of time, you were having like 3,000
baptisms a day. Mhm. Mhm. You know, not
because you were you were promised any
riches. You were never promised any
riches. It was simply by preaching the
gospel of Jesus Christ. And soon after
the persecution of the Christians
happened by the Romans because they felt
threatened by this movement that grew so
fast
and not because of oh they were getting
more being richer than the Roman Empire
or anything like that, right? But it was
purely because their faith on Jesus was
so strong. They didn't care for their
own lives. They didn't care for their
own possessions. Well, and then
according to the definition of of
prosperity gospel, the people who were
slaughtered by lions and eaten alive by
lions to give their lives for Christ
were apparently not having faith. That
doesn't that doesn't really make any
sense at all. I think they have tons of
faith and I'm sure those people will be
in heaven someday. Okay. Matthew
19:23-26 says, "But then Jesus said to
his disciples, assurely I say to you
that it is hard for a rich man to enter
the kingdom of heaven. And again I say
to you, it is easier for a camel to go
through the eye of a needle than for a
rich man to enter the kingdom of God.
When his disciples heard it, they were
greatly astonished, saying, "Who can be
saved?" But Jesus looked at them and
said to them, "With this with men, this
is impossible. With God, all things are
possible." Again, there's this concept
here of wealth being something that
actually makes life more difficult or
your spiritual walk more difficult.
Because let's be honest, there is more
temptation, right? There's a lot of
temptation to be like, well, I can spend
money on this and that and that and and
um oh, I can um you know um be more
self-sufficient and you feel less of a
need for God. If you are absolutely
living on the streets, I bet you you'll
be crying out to God. But it's a lot
harder when you have a lot of money in
the bank account. Again, there's no sin
in that. There's nothing wrong with it.
But I think this is portraying the
concept of like if God gives you money,
he is trusting you with it for his cause
to share the love of Jesus and not to be
selfish about it. And I think it can be
used when you have money to actually
grow closer to God because you have to
be on your knees more. You have to pray
more to ask God, Lord, help me to use it
for your glory and help me overcome the
temptation. You got to realize that God
trusted you. Exactly. what he gives you.
Exactly. He trusts you to use it, right?
Yes. But it's not a standard. It's not a
given that we should all just be wealthy
and we should just claim wealth in the
name of Jesus and snap our fingers and
it will happen because that's not how
the Bible portrays wealth in the first
place. It's a struggle. It's it actually
makes your spiritual walk harder. And so
if this is a standard, then that
completely clashes with what the Bible
says. Yeah. Yeah. Heartbreak.
All right, I can do this.
Hurry.
[Music]
There are conventional ways of sharing
the gospel, but some may need a
different way of doing things. Um, never
mind. A way that gets the message out
with confidence.
Wow, cool shirt. What's it mean? Oh,
thank you. You know, we're all made with
a unique fingerprint, but we're all
God's artwork. Wow. Where'd you get it?
Lightwear. Wear your witness.
[Music]
Matthew 6:24 says, "No one can serve two
masters, for either he will hate the one
and love the other, or else he will be
loyal to the one and despise the other."
You cannot serve God and Mammon. Now, um
you know, let's let's not guess what
Mammon means. But then again, let's go
to the strong concordance and see what
it says there in the original language.
What's the meaning of it? It says
mammon, treasure or riches. Interesting.
Where it is personified and opposed to
God. Mhm. So personified like like like
it almost becomes this person, this this
this
tangible emotional thing that you can
get attached to, right? That's opposed
to God. They say money speaks. Yeah. And
it does. Yeah. So, yeah. So, I think
that's you know the Bible's very clear
about it how you cannot serve two
masters both God and riches where it is
personified and opposed to God. Right?
But when you start serving
money now people might say I don't serve
money. No. But are you a slave to it?
Are you falling for its temptations?
That's where it becomes a problem. Does
it mean that you should just give up all
of your money and empty your bank
account? I can't speak for God. Maybe
that's what he's telling you to do.
Maybe not. Maybe he's just saying, "No,
I I want to teach you again to use it
differently and overcome your
temptations." Right? God knows.
Something to pray about. Okay. So then
Tyler, he goes into Joel Olstein's
church and he has an interesting
experience here. Take a moment to
worship the Lord with our tithes and our
offerings. We want to thank you for your
generosity and your donations. Together,
we're impacting people with hope and the
the love of Christ all over the world.
Proverbs 18 says, "When you give, it can
open doors." That's what we're believing
for you, among other things, that in
2024, you're going to see God open some
doors that you couldn't open on your
own. Happens when you're when you're
faithful, when you honor God with your
life, with your decisions, and of
course, with your funds as well. And
that's what you guys do every week. So,
get that down in your spirit. God can
open doors that no person can shut in
your business, in your finances, in
every good area for your children, for
the schools they need to go to go
through. But did the attendants come
here to worship God or to get a
motivational speech from Joel and a
blessing from God? But of course, no
matter how charismatic Joel was or how
blessed his hairline is, his church
preaches that the more faith and money I
give to God, the more blessed my life
is. And at the end of the day,
financially giving to God, or rather,
Joel's church is essential to open doors
that are impossible to open on my own.
And this sales pitch works. Joel, how
you doing? Good. How about you? I'm
doing good. Could you sign my book? I'd
be glad to. All right. Thank you so
much. Thank you so much. I'm from
Austin, Texas. Joel, I have a question
for you. Do you think you've used the
word the Lord's word to profit?
Like grossly. Do you just do you think
you distorted the the Lord's word to
make money?
Appreciate you coming.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Sorry. What do you
What do you think? He ran away from that
question pretty uh quickly. Yeah.
If you're doing right something right
for the Lord, you have nothing to hide,
right? I would agree. Yeah. So if if
you're running away from a question that
though we know Tyler's intention here
was to like de debunk or expose
uh he kind of did ask it in a way that
looked sincere, you know, and he just
immediately uncomfortable just like no
uh let me get out of here. It's probably
a question he's heard many times
probably. But again, yeah, I mean, Joel
Ostein is someone that is well known for
giving motivational speeches and
prosperity gospel and I think he even
received Kanye West on his church once
when Kanye really first converted to
Christianity, right? Wow. Uh he's Yeah,
it's uh if you got nothing to hide.
Yeah. If you have the Lord on your side,
if God is for us, who is against us?
Mhm.
Answer the question, man. Honestly, I
think that any genuine Christian should
be able to be asked anything about what
you believe. Mhm. And that genuine
question Christian should be able to
back it up with scripture, you know.
Yeah. So like you should be able to be
absolutely grilled to the nines, but you
know, if we study our Bibles, we should
be able to stand up for that and and and
it is written. Yeah. Say it is written.
D. And in this case, I think for obvious
reasons, he couldn't even bring up any
scriptures to support his case. Mhm. You
know, it's an uncomfortable situation.
And I think it just speaks truth to
where it's at, right? Because if you say
you're a Christian, show me from
scripture why you live this life and why
you make these decisions. So, yeah,
speaks for itself. So then Tyler goes to
Revival Ministries International
and this is where the uh manifesting
happens. Can you tell a little about
that because you kind of looked into
this before, right? Like what it is. So
manifesting uh from what I understand is
when you put all your thoughts and all
your um imagination into manifesting
something. It's like you think so much
about about it, you repeat yourself. I'm
going to get this. I'm going to become
that and all the other that eventually
it all happens. It's almost like the
universe shifts and aligns to so that
everything can work out for you. That's
from what I understand. And it's
something that is pretty prominent
because it doesn't really take much
effort if you just manifest it. Oh, I'm
manifesting that one day I'll become
rich. Well, I'm manifesting that I'm
going to become fit and healthy and
wealthy. And it's replacing it's pretty
much
it becomes your own god. Mhm. When you
don't want to believe in god. Yeah. In
in a way because you can you have the
power in yourself to make something
happen. Yeah. When God says you know I'm
the vine. You're the branches. Without
me you cannot do anything. Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah. So yeah this um
manifesting can be really a really
dangerous thing. Honestly, in this
documentary, they also talked about that
some of these pastors, the word goes
around that they also are called or call
themselves little gods and that, you
know, you the pastors call themselves
little gods. Yeah. Some of them. And
that you yourself are a little god
basically. Um and and you know, it's
interesting that you brought this up
about this idea of manifesting because
this is very much of a new age concept.
We did a episode a couple of weeks ago.
We'll put a link in the description
about this guy who was grew up Christian
but then um got totally hooked to the
new age and the re the ways he did that
was actually through the idea of
manifesting because he read a book the
secret the secret and I think it's uh
growing and thinking yourself rich and
and so all of this basically is the law
of attraction which is just a different
version of manifesting. Yeah. the law of
attraction where you say if you think
about it and if you really want it then
it's going to happen and so you can
think and will yourself rich. This is
basically the same thing but then they
put God into it and they um have this
idea of if you don't have faith then it
won't happen. Right. Right. And
um you'll see in this clip here a lot of
this has to do with healing. And so
healing from sickness for example. So
you manifest if you have a sick child,
you manifest as your child gets sick. So
the concept of Oh, really? Yes. So
everything that happened is pretty much
your fault is what they're saying. Did
you manifest your child to be sick?
Well, if you don't have faith, if you
manifest that your child is going to be
healed and the child dies, for example,
then you just didn't have enough faith,
which really results in spiritual
manipulation, right? And that destroys
your faith in God completely. Like why
would you believe in God like that if
because it confuses you 100%. Yeah. So
so I just want to throw out there as
well that um the the the new age
manifestation idea is not biblical. No.
But you still what you think still
matters what you think about yourself.
The Bible says what you think in your
mind that is what you are. And your what
your mouth speaks your mouth speaks of
what the heart is abundant. Yeah. Yeah.
Right. So it still matters that you do
think thoughts of joy, thoughts of
peace. Absolutely. And you pray to God
and all that stuff. Yeah. But you got to
you have to understand that you can't do
anything of of yourself. It's always God
doing it for you. Yeah. Right. So it is
manifestation is a distorted idea that
you can you have power of in of in and
of yourself to do something for you.
Yeah. And we'll look at a couple of
texts from scripture in just a second
after this clip. But it's also the idea
of
the Bible is full of accepting the
Lord's will for your life. Like
surrendering to God's will.
Understanding that though we don't
understand,
God knows what's best and he is the most
loving, kind, perfect God and father and
he would never do anything to hurt us.
And so for us, we might not even
understand in our lifetime, but we know
that he understands and that he has
reasons to allow things to happen. He
can he can see things in the future that
we can't even see. And that's why he
either if we have though we have faith,
he e either allows that something to
happen or says, "Okay, I will I will do
as you asked in faith with a genuine
heart." So, you know, that's another
aspect to that as well. But yeah, let's
take a look at this place where Tyler
goes to. It's basically like a school, I
guess, for these Christians to learn how
to manifest and how to have faith and do
these kinds of healings. And uh yeah,
we'll see what he's up to. Clearly, Joel
didn't want to give me anything besides
an opportunity to buy his newest book.
So, I headed to the River Church in
Tampa, Florida, that claims to be able
to perform miracles and heal things like
cancer, AIDS, blindness, deafness,
Alzheimer's, and anything else you can
think of.
I see you full of the life of God. I see
you full of God's healing power. Oh, I
see your bank account even overflowing.
Hallelujah. Oh, I I see the bank telling
you, you got to go somewhere. We've had
some creative miracles in here. I told
you about the guy who had the colon and
was using the bathroom in the back and
then the power of God touched him the
next day. The Lord rerouted, gave him a
miracle and he was using the bathroom,
right? Healed him. There was another guy
who came. His name was Scott. He was
homeless. He had been backsliden. He'd
had diabetes. He'd have had toes that
amputated. His body was just weak, weak,
weak. And uh he'd heard about healing
school. So he pulled himself in his weak
state out of his wheelchair into his
bike and rode 5 miles to get here. And
the Lord helped and he made it. So he
was out of the wheelchair and he was
biking like the Lord strengthened him
because he just said, "I I need help."
It was almost like his body was so
messed up that he was just like, "Lord,
you got to do something." On his one
foot, they cut off a couple toes and
then by mistake had severed a tendon.
And then on the other foot, they took
off a couple toes and they had to remove
the bone that went down the the part of
the foot. This is what he said later
while he was telling the testimony. He
said the power of God came into his
foot. He felt his foot start burning. He
went back to his seat and the Lord said,
"Check your foot." Well, when he went to
do it, it was a bone. The Lord regrrew a
bone in his foot. That's a creative
power. The people that are often times
the easiest to deceive are the ones with
the best intentions. These people are so
often victimized. They're innocent.
They're lovely people. And they go into
these churches wanting to find God,
wanting to find community. And they're
perfect victims for people who say, "Oh,
well, I see that your your uncle has
cancer." You know how you deal with
that? You you give a little money into
the tithe bucket. That's you know,
before you know it, they don't know any
better. Healing theology is probably the
most disgusting um version of
Christianity out there that I see
because you see people dying literally
because you see people stop taking their
medications, giving away all their
money, giving away their estates because
they're desperate cuz they just don't
want to die from dermal cancer. Uh my
knees hurt, right? Knee be healed. Be
healed in I command healing to my knee
right now in Jesus name. Like whipping
God into shape, right? It's like you're
you're going to jerk him over here and
be like heal that. Who who are you? Who
do you think you are? I don't believe
that God doesn't work miracles. I still
I just don't believe that there are men
or women out there that have the ability
like a superhero to just go on command
touch somebody and heal them. That's
God's sovereign will and we are to ask
for that and and he can do it if he so
chooses. One thing like I said it takes
God out of the equation. A lot of in a
lot of your things you don't have a
relationship with God. It's it's all
about you. How big is your faith? How
much have you prayed so you can build up
your faith and you can have this power.
One of the biggest things about this is
it's a faith it's a literal faith
killer. When you are praying, let's say
you have a daughter or a son that's
going through a horrible deal. And you
have this pastor, so-called pastor
saying, you could speak it. Speak it.
Speak it. Speak it. Speak what you want
and it will be done. If you have the
faith, it'll be done. And you truly have
faith. You truly believe what the pastor
is telling you. You truly pray with with
true faith and it never happens. Where
does that put you in your faith? So,
this is a complicated situation because
the Bible does talk about, you know,
Jesus says if you have faith that you
you can move mountains if you have faith
like a mustard seed. So I can see the
difficulty of understanding this topic.
But you know in actual fact I I once had
this question and I actually asked this
to uh do you know who Jim Caster is?
Mhm. So he's a missionary from the
Philippines who actually lives on no
income. He just gets invited everywhere
to go and you know pray for them. He has
a prayer ministry or go speak somewhere
or whatever and people just feed him and
give him a place to stay. And and so I
asked him, I said, "What does it mean
when Jesus said, "Ask and it shall be
given to you. Seek and you shall find."
And that's a much longer discussion we
can really um put into this episode, but
I do want to encourage the people at
home. We'll put a link in the
description for this podcast. Um it's
unlin on YouTube or you can listen to on
Spotify, Apple Podcasts. Very
fascinating conversation. But you know I
I do want to talk about this idea of
what we talked about earlier how we when
we pray and we have faith
there's always this idea of like is it
God's will right and the Bible talks
about this 1 John 5:14 now this is the
confidence we have in him that if we ask
anything according to his will he hears
us and so I really like what Jesus did
when um he was on the cross he said in
Luke 22 242 Father, if it is your will,
take this cup away from me.
Nevertheless, not my will, but your will
be done. And this is such a powerful
statement from Jesus because Jesus,
he didn't even he didn't even bow down
to his own will. He didn't even choose
to follow his own will. Mhm. And he was
God as well. He is God. That's right. He
is God. And he still chose to follow the
plan of salvation. It's like, "Father,
if it is your will, I will do your
will." Not even Jesus
uh you know decided to go away and and
do what he wants. Yeah. And it's
interesting that now we're always like,
"Oh, follow your heart. Do what you
want. Do not w this should be the whole
of the law." Not even Jesus did that.
Mhm. And you know, it's interesting the
the aspect of like the faith. Um,
many times in the Bible when Jesus
healed people, he didn't physically go
there and touch them. Mhm. Many times it
was just like
they would be like, "Oh Lord, you healed
me. You healed me. You healed me." He's
like, "No, your fa your faith healed
you." That's right. The centurion came
like my servant and was like, "Go home.
I didn't need to go with you. your faith
has healed you. It's like I haven't seen
this faith anywhere in Jerusalem, right?
It's because it is by faith alone. You
don't need to, you know, many times when
people came to Jesus,
Jesus wasn't even expecting them. He
just stopped because he was he had
compassion on them. So really, it is
between you and God. in your faith and
God in your faith is not measured on
whether or not you were healed or not.
Just because you were not healed, it
does not mean you don't have faith. Mhm.
Cuz remember, everything happens with a
purpose. Yeah. Because everything
happens for the good of those who love
God. That's a promise. You know, Job
understood that. Y Job I don't think
ever once he asked God to heal him. He
just understood God gives, God takes
away. Takes away. Blessed be the name of
the Lord. Your faith is not measured on
whether you're healed or not or whether
you think God heard you or not because
he he he listens. Mhm. Right. Because
understanding God's will
uh for your life and wanting to follow
God's will for your life. It it's I like
to say it like this. Um the difference
there's a difference between you asking
your you you writing your wants on a on
a piece of paper and asking God to sign
it. Hey Lord, this is what I want. Can
you sign it? Mhm. And on the other hand,
you have a blank piece of paper and you
give it to God. It's like Lord, write
down your will for me for my life. Yeah.
That's what faith is. Now, is it is it
wrong to ask God for anything? No.
But it's always still within his will.
Mhm. And if he and if it's not his will,
he knows what why. Just be at peace with
it. It does not mean you don't have
faith. That's right. Yeah. And and I I
like what you're saying like have a
blank paper. Um I think of the story of
I think it was King Hezekiah with a
sundial, you know, like he he was
basically um sick, you know, and he's
like, "God, will you heal me?" And God's
like, "Okay, you know, I'll listen." But
it wasn't what was best for Hezekiah
because afterward he went haywire. You
know, and I've heard of stories of
Christians where people prayed and said,
"Lord, just just heal this person. Heal
this person. Heal this person." Not
praying, but your will be done because
you know what's best. Person was healed
and then later on left the faith and
died an unbeliever. It was better for
that person to die being in the faith,
right? And still loving and trusting
Jesus. So, I think it's really hard when
you I I have not been in a situation, I
don't know if you have, where a loved
one is sick and you really want that
person to heal.
I can't imagine what it must be like to
be in that situation when you're
absolutely desperate because for that
person to be healed because you don't
want to lose that person or you don't
want to see that person suffer. And it's
hard to understand like why would God
allow this? But you know, we we can see
from the scriptures that we can trust
God, that he knows what's best. And if a
loving earthly parent would want to do
the absolute best for that child,
knowing the full scope, the full story,
and maybe doing something that the child
doesn't understand, but the parent is
like, I know this is best for you. Then
like what about God who is our heavenly
father who is our creator who is above
all human capacity above all human
understanding.
Right? I I love there's um there's this
this quote from an author a Christian
author who says um God is a thousand
ways to provide for us of which we know
nothing. Yeah. Love that. And I think
it's so true. And I think that's the
kind of faith that God absolutely honors
whether it results in healing and what
we want or not to still believe in God
like Job did. That is where I believe
even there your your riches are stored
up in heaven. Your result for your faith
will come. Mhm. So, let's take a look at
this last clip here where he goes into
um Benny Hinn's church, runs off the
stage, but what happens after is is
I don't I don't have words for it
because it was so intense. Just watch
it, okay? Let me know.
Betty hit is a false.
Enough is enough, brother. Enough is
enough. Enough is enough. Peaceful.
Peaceful.
Jesus Christ.
He's abusing the word of God. Somebody
help the dear man out. It's all right.
No problem.
It's all right, brother. Calm down.
While I was getting the George Floyd
treatment, fighting for each breath, my
cameraman ran for his life to avoid a
similar fate. So, we're going to get
into the scriptures. Can we do that now?
Only to get captured
and beaten with his own camera. I was I
was hit twice.
I was hit twice with a golf car,
assaulted by a person here. Then they
tackled me and threw me into the middle
of a reactive road. And after that, they
kept beating my head and then they
grabbed my camera and they were trying
to delete the footage actively. I just
got hog tied, body slammed and tackled.
Posasha went running and apparently they
clipped him with a golf cart and
proceeded to beat his head in and delete
the footage. So things are not looking
good. We are headed to the hospital
right now where he is going to make sure
he's alive. Apparently they deleted all
the footage from the camera. So, it's
gone. Um, I've been trespassed. I'm
headed to the hospital making sure
Pasha's alive. In an ironic twist of
fate, the church themselves beat the of
us. From what it sounds like, beat the
out of Pasha. So, we're going to
check in.
They They tampered with this video
evidence. They deleted the first. They
could not touch the second one. How How
are you? What happened there? What did
they do? They ran me over with a golf
cart twice. I'm going to die today. He
threw me into the middle of the roadway
in front of a semi truck. give you my
head. I'm Like four or five
people were on top of me. Yeah. On my
head, ankles, knees. They snag the
camera out. They hit my head with the
camera. I'm not going to say that they
are completely innocent. But in no way
that is Christlike. Mhm. In no way it is
something that Christ would do. Mm-m.
Christ offered himself to be beat, not
I'm going to beat somebody else up. This
is brutal. Mhm. Honestly,
I can't
defend either of those actions. Mhm.
Because honestly going up in this like
it was not really peaceful. He said it
was peaceful, but no. But so debatable,
but still nobody should get beaten up
for that. Mhm. Like no, that is um Yeah,
just sad. I mean, that was I would say
that was even an attempt of murder when
you try to run somebody over with a golf
cart and throw them in front of a
semi-truck and stuff if that's what
happened, you know, but it seems foring.
Mhm. What exactly like being disruptive?
That was live streamed. Either way, are
you going to beat up your own cameraman
from the church because he also caught
that on camera? Like that's true. Yeah.
Yeah. I remember there's a story from
the time of the dark ages in the time of
the reformation when the you know there
were Protestants who um stood up against
the faith system at the time that was
very damaging to the Christian faith and
they protested.
Like I said, 50 50 million people were
were killed, Christians, genuine
Christians. 100 million maybe. Um the
the numbers are very we we don't know
because there was no technology at the
time and these people were just burned
at the stake and like drowned by the
millions. So we don't know. But um there
was this man, a Dutch man who um was
pursued um and he was going to get
arrested and killed. And it was winter.
He crossed the ice. He made it across
safely, but one of the guys trying to
catch him fell through the ice and
didn't know how to swim and would have
drowned. This man, Dutch man, walked
back, pulled him out of the ice knowing
he was going to get arrested, knowing he
was going to die. He basically saved his
his killer, right? And then, well, the
other ones caught up with him, so they
caught him and took him anyway and and
got him to geted. He got executed or
martyed. Yeah. And so I'm like that is
the love of Jesus. That's the attitude
of Jesus. That's what he did for us. He
died. Well, the Bible says, "Well, we
are yet his enemies, right? Because we
are in sin, but because of Jesus, we can
now be set free from sin. We can
overcome our temptations, overcome our
sin because of him. This is how they
will know that you are my disciples if
you love one another and if you lay down
your life for your brother." Mhm. So,
yeah. And to me, you know, there's a lot
of comments in there on on on this video
from both Christians and atheists. And
you can see the idea that most of these
unbelievers or atheists have about
Christianity that I bet you a lot of it
has been shaped by absolute Christian
hypocrisy. Like this. Take a look at
this one. As a Christian myself, this
type of preaching disgusts me. Thank you
for exposing this perverted doctrine.
and Tyler Oliver even hearted that
comment. But then 13,000 likes. This is
like the top comment. 84 replies. So
let's take a look at these replies. So
deceived you are. You'd rather have
Diddian Epstein with the money.
Perverted. L M AO. Clearly, you don't
know the first thing about pervertedness
that goes on in all religions. I mean,
this is the concept, the idea that
people have. And I don't blame him if
this is all the Christianity you get to
see. I mean, no, there's so much more
out there. Obviously, there are genuine
Christians out there, but if this is
like the the the televised megaurches
that you see on the internet or on a TV
and you think that's all it is, like,
oh, if I want to be be a child of God, I
have to empty my bank account to make
another man rich. I wouldn't want to be
a Christian like that. Yeah. I mean,
what example are you setting? Mhm. Yeah.
Jesus Jesus does says that if you
scandal any of these little ones in the
faith, it is better for you to, you
know, tie a rock to your neck and jump
in the water and drown. Mhm. It's like
it's not easy language. It's not light
light language. It's pretty strong
language to say that like hey your
consequ the consequences of your actions
are so bad
that it is better for you to drown. Mhm.
Than than to you know continue doing
this. Yeah. And so after this is Matthew
18 it continues to talk about you know
woe to the world because of offenses for
offenses must come but woe to that man
by whom offense comes. And then verse
eight, if your hand or foot causes you
to sin, cut it off and cast it from you.
It is better for you to enter into life
maimed ma lame or maimed rather than
having two hands or two feet to be cast
into the everlasting fire. So I wonder
if this idea of like the millstone
around your neck is really everything
here is symbolic. Obviously, he's not
saying like, you know, after yourself if
Exactly. But but it it I think it's
symbolic language saying
there's consequences in the judgment if
you don't repent from this. Okay. So,
and then somebody else says, "The
funniest part about all of this is all
you haters don't like them because what
they say is true." So, this person
agrees with the prosperity gospel. If
they didn't deserve those millions, they
wouldn't have them stop hating. It's
better that they have it and they're
preaching Jesus than some slow-mo.
You know, here's the question. Are they
preaching Jesus?
I don't think so. It reminds me of
Jim Jones. Mhm. Jim Jones, I don't think
he preached a prosperity gospel, but he
preached some sort of gospel that he
called it Christianity under the
pretense of Christianity. And they were
hated. Of course, the other haters had
to move. I think it was Argentina or
Colombia, some other country and then
Jonesville happened and then the whole
um
situation there happened as well where
everyone off themselves, everyone drank
poison, the Kool-Aid. Yeah, the
Kool-Aid. And uh all while believing in
this false idea of the gospel and I'm
sure he used the Bible just like these
people are using the Bible, right?
And you can't you can't say
that they did the right thing if you
actually know your Bible. Mhm. So this
to say that the the word of God can be
distorted in so many ways. Yep. That it
if you don't study your Bible, you're
easily deceived. Mhm. So, if you're
defending people uh from the prosperity
gospel and you go and read your Bible,
then
I mean, how are you still defending
them? God God promised because God said,
"Look at the liies of the field." Mhm.
They don't go to work. They don't uh
they don't know have food harvested or
anything like that. But yet I tell you
that their clothing are more are
prettier than anything that Solomon ever
had when Solomon was the richest man on
earth. That's right. Right. Because God
provides. God providing does not mean
you're you're storing treasures on
earth. You yourself like God can give
you rich blessings and wealth if he
wants to if it's his will. But it's not
one plus one is two. Yeah. Exactly. It's
it's not like the Lord is my shepherd. I
shall not want. Mhm. is not talking
about the Lord is my shepherd. I will
have abundance of things for myself
because it's it's not about you. It was
never about you. It's about Christ.
Right. And that's why he gives you uh
according to what you deserve. Mhm.
Right. But it's if the devil can be
really subtle when you know trying to
lead people away from what the Bible
actually says. That's right. You know,
in Matthew 7 starting in verse 15 also
says, "Beware of false prophets who come
to you in sheep's clothing." You know,
when you think about a lamb or a sheep
and John 1:29, it says that that Jesus
is is the lamb of God. So, this is like
appearing to be Christlike, right? But
on the inside, they're wolves. Inwardly,
they are ravenous wolves. So, you will
know them by their fruits. What does the
Bible say is the fruit? Fruit of the
spirit. It's it's patience. It's love.
It's kindness. It's goodness. It's all
of those things, right? Um, do men
gather grapes from thorn bushes or figs
from thistles? So, in other words, do
you find this fruit on those kind of
trees? No. Even so, every good tree
bears good fruit, but a bad tree bears
bad fruit. A good tree cannot bear bad
fruit, nor can a bad tree bear good
fruit. Every tree that does not bear
good fruit is cut down and thrown into
the fire. This is talking about the end
judgment. Therefore, by their fruits,
you shall know them. So yeah, I think
you can determine by their fruits if the
prosperity gospel or if these preachers
are in it for the right thing, if they
are biblically correct and sound. And um
as much as as I care about these people,
I care about both the individuals who
are deceived and about the pastors
involved because Christ tells us to love
everybody, right? Including the people
we don't agree with. I don't have a lot
of respect for them or what they do. But
I I don't see the fruit. I I don't see
the fruit that currently their works
don't show me that they have love in
their hearts for these people for their
flock because they are deceiving them
and they are robbing them of their money
and taking it for themselves. Personally
to me that's not fruit. Now I can't read
the heart. I don't know what's going on
the heart. But I think on the outside
it's clear that this is not from the
Bible. This is not from Jesus. And this
is fully misrepresenting Christianity.
And that was the one of the reasons why
I feel like feel like it's important to
react to these kind of videos to portray
what does the Bible really say? What was
Jesus really like? Yeah. And what does
he want his followers to be really like?
Mhm. Yeah. So if there's if anyone
watching
um is interested in knowing more about
this, there's a documentary that I
watched. I highly recommend. I think
it's a three-part series. It's called
the American Gospel. Mhm. Which it
focuses more on on this and uh the
origins of it and the the scheme the
bigger scheme of things um with and it
gets all sorts of different perspectives
and interestingly enough prayer gospel
is not all about the money as well,
right? It's about all sorts of aspects
of life. So that I I think it's it's an
interesting documentary. I would I would
recommend for that as well. Awesome. If
you like this video, like, subscribe,
and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos. And drop
a comments below, and we'll try to get
back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]